they say prevention is better than cure
and Shona is living proof she says
regular scans saved her life after
battling liver disease and Cancer all
before her 31st birthday if I wasn't
under surveillance I
because the the side the symptoms of
liver cancer are not usually found until
later on until it's too late
I wouldn't have been able to have a
liver transplant and that to me even
thinking about that now is horrendous
like I've managed to get some of my life
back hi Mark how are you doing the NHS
is now offering the same chance for
others free mots for the liver in trucks
like this one scans for those
communities most at risk the idea of us
having the van is to allow flexibility
to see patients anywhere we've taken a
lot of walk-ins as well so anyone that's
attending Services can just pop in and
ask for a liver check and from that we
can give patients kind of instant
results straight away on the day and
then explain everything to them and the
checks are working identifying more than
800 people with damage that could lead
to liver cancer
the aim to reach 22 000 people by this
summer this is a fantastic initiative to
reach out and ensure we can get people
coming forward early for assessment the
earlier we diagnose cancer the more we
can cure so if we catch liver cancer
early we can cure between 70 and 90
percent of people for Shona now in
remission scans for those at risk are a
no-brainer if it was one of your loved
ones that was going to go through
something would you want them to get
checked because you would want them to
be around for longer and you would want
them to get treatment so why don't you
treat yourself like that advice that
could be life-changing Saba Chowdhury
Sky News